toshiba was never a market leader in pcs
or laptops but they did hold a
significant stake in the market in the
early 2000s from 2001 to 2009
Koshiro is almost always in the top five
PC makers in terms of market share but
since 2009 they have never been able to
get the top pipe again but to this day
the iconic Toshiba sign is in Times
Square so it's clear that they're still
around so what is sochi about today and
what happened to their laptops make sure
to stick around till the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to hari sadhus Toshiba actually
originated from two different companies
the first of which was Jabari Shamu show
this cup is actually originally called
Tanaka Shaku show and was founded by
Tanaka
he's a she's in July of 1875 it was
renamed in 1904 and this cookie was
Ashley Japan's first manufacturer of
telegraphic equipment they were a major
manufacturer of heavy electro machinery
and in modern Japan as a world
industrial power ask for the other
company he was called Hawking at sucia
and was founded in 1890 it was later
renamed to tokyo denki in 1899 this
company was Japan's first producer of
incandescent electric lamps but they
soon diversified into other consumer
arenas as well later on the two
companies merged and created a new
company Tokyo Jabbar would Denki as you
may have already noticed if you take the
first parts of Tokyo and she borrow we
get towed and Chiba and that's how it
was nicknamed Toshiba Toshiba didn't
become the official name until 1978
Toshiba grew rapidly with a nice
combination of organic growth and many
different acquisitions as well
throughout the 1940s and 1950s they
mainly bought engineering and primary
industry firms but after the 1950s as
Japan was recovering from World War two
Toshiba really started to diversify
themselves they had several new groups
including Toshiba music in 1960 Toshiba
International Corporation 1970s Toshiba
Alto equipment in 1974 Toshiba Chemical
as well Sochi but landing at a college
in 1989 and several others as well on
top of this Toshiba was also responsible
for many of Japan's firsts for example
they invented Japan's first radar 1912
and they invented their first TAC
digital computer in 1954 Toshiba was
growing very fast and it was just a
matter of time before they became a
global conglomerate and in the 1980s and
1990s Toshiba rose to goal of prominence
as Japan offered cheap loans subsidies
and limited competition Japan really
wanted to focus on fostering domestic
technology giants and exporting parts
abroad and in 1985 toshiba attained
their peak achievement which is the
creation of the t 1100 this was the
first mass-market laptop that was IBM
compatible this meant that the laptops
have very similar software and
components to IBM's very popular desktop
PCs from 1981 at first the t11 er
project didn't have much hope and the
only way that the project leader was
able to get approval for was by
promising that he would be able to sell
10,000 years in the first year this was
a very ambitious goal especially in an
unproven category and as a result the
superiors definitely had their doubts
however the high similarity with IBM
desktops really do of the popularity for
a T 1100 and allowed him to get over
10,000 sales in the very first year and
then just a couple of years later
Toshiba invented probably their most
important veterans of all time which is
NAND flash NAND flash is an essential
part of most modern hardware devices as
it is essential in RAM and storage
devices and flash is simply memory chip
but what makes it unique is that it was
a first memory chip to able to retain
information without power this made a
revolutionary for cameras mp3 players
smartphones and USB flash drives and to
this day NAND flash is a very important
part of technology and as a result
Toshiba's still a market leader in terms
of NAND flash as of 2017 Toshiba held
17.4% of a NAND flash market only beaten
out by Sam
in the 1990s and 2000's they were a top
laptop vendor and maintain their lead in
net flash their laptops and computers
filled aisles of electronic stores all
around the world and these were really
their golden years 17.8 percent of all
computer sales in retail stores in
United States were from Toshiba but by
the early 2000s with the interest
popularity in lowering PC prices organic
consumer started buying pcs cheaper
manufacturers such as Acer Asus and
Lenovo really start Excel estimated
cheap home brand laptops Toshiba and
Sony laptops were highly sought after as
they were hiring laptops
that's more ordinary consumers came in
to market the craze from laptops they
died out laptop became an ordinary
household item like a washer or a
microwave at this point consumers who
are looking for the cheapest one that
they could find or an elite laptop like
from Apple not to say that other
companies don't make a laptop as good as
Apple as Apple is very slow to update
their laptops offer Apple is a huge
lifestyle brand that consumers are
willing to spend more money for unlike
Toshiba which the ordinary consumer
doesn't really care about this
competitive squeezed to the top and the
bottom along with the 2008 recession
really destroyed toshiba's presence
their annual revenues shrink about 80
percent from 2007 2015 just take a look
at this chart in 2007 they made upwards
of 30 billion dollars in sales from the
PC industry but it's not 15 that's
cranked to merely 5 billion that is a
very significant drop-off this led to
them have a negative annual operating
profits every single year from 2008 to
except for one year in 2010 this can be
explained by her lack of adaptation to
changing market they neither offered
cheaper laptops it could be with a
through Zeus nor their brand themselves
as a lifestyle brand like a beard Apple
doesn't let them to completely withdraw
from a non-japanese market in 2015 like
2016 they completely exited the consumer
PC market outside of Japan however the
continue sell to businesses outside of
Japan in just 20 years from 1996 to 2016
their PC market share dropped from
almost 20 percent to just 5 percent this
truly was a tragic turn of events for
Toshiba at this point while I did feel
in some arenas as new betters came in
they were still doing pretty well and
they weren't even considering bankruptcy
while they weren't as biggest before you
were definitely doing really well in
Japan and they were definitely
self-sustainable but the company's
reputation would take a huge beating
when a major scandal was exposed in 2015
a whistleblower initiated a full-fledged
investigation which revealed that tow
she was overstating their operating
profits for several years they were
overstating their operating profits by
up to 1.2 billion dollars during their
rapid downfall in the PC industry this
was clearly in an effort to please
shareholders from at Satoshi Nishida a
CEO of the company
it really was a shame seeing him going
to such measures to save the company as
he was there when they were building T
11 hundreds he said unrealistically high
numbers for operating profit margin are
simply unattainable for the 334 page
report from the investigation it was
revealed that even Ishida himself would
encourage floating in numbers
this scandal didn't cause the demise of
Toshiba but a clearly revealed that
there was bigger issues within Toshiba
itself managers were so used to
delivering good news and leaders simply
didn't want to hear anything other than
good news this culture heavily limited
the company from actually identifying
issues and figure out how to solve them
instead they kept making the same
mistakes and were forced to try to fix
them afterwards furthermore in Japanese
companies that employs just all the
orders of their superiors without any
thinking they don't analyze if it's a
good idea or the right thing to do this
is terrible fright identifying solving
issues and innovating one of the biggest
reasons for Toshiba's downfall was their
unwise investment in nuclear power in
Toshiba invested 5.4 billion dollars
into westinghouse which is a us-based
their power facility builder before this
yet no experience in the nuclear power
industry but they saw a good future so
they decided to invest in it
other countries such as Vietnam and
India also saw good futures for nuclear
power as I also coordinate of money into
it but everything changed for Toshiba in
2011 when the tsunami destroyed Japan's
Fukushima Daiichi plant after this Japan
closed down all of its nuclear reactors
as there was growing global shani
towards investing in nuclear power
there was also bad news for Westinghouse
Chicago Britain iron whom they had
contracted to build for nuclear reactors
for them and touch selling the division
to Westinghouse and soon enough less
neons discovered that their projects
were simply too expensive to pursue not
to mention the huge negative stigma
surrounding them
and as a result in March of 2017 they
filed for bankruptcy this was terrible
news for Toshiba as Toshiba and I spent
six billion dollars in development costs
over the several years they owned
Westinghouse which is actually more than
what they paid for Westinghouse itself
they lost over ten billion dollars of
nuclear power and this financially
destroyed them even further
they were so distraught they even
considered signs of NAND flash business
which had the greatest chance of
survival in the end Toshiba nuclear
investments took a huge toll on them
financially today because she was just a
shelter for mercilessly
just like other Japanese manufacturing
giants this was a similar fate even to
Sony and almost a Nintendo as well the
problem for all t japanese companies is
that they're stuck in this middle were
there in between innovative products and
cheap asian manufacturing as an adviser
to Japan's Ministry of Economy Trade and
Industry once said unfortunately in
every industry except for the automobile
Japan will lose its lead to another
country for Japan more destruction is
necessary before change human take place
or at least more time this generation of
complacent salaryman must retire for a
new generation to come in and start
innovating
until then even Japan's strongest
companies are going to keep unraveling
the
- Toshiba really sends a strong signal
to Japan and the Japanese that there
needs to be a huge structural reform in
order for them to be competitive in the
new world once again as that visor also
said what cut is here won't get there
any longer
in the end Toshiba was a market leader
and a pioneer of technology they had a
slew of different divisions to
manufacture everything from electronic
products to infrastructure systems and
storage devices however over the past 20
years there has been a significant shift
in consumer demand for cheap products or
more expensive ones people simply didn't
want something in the middle they want a
capable cheap laptop or a high-end
MacBook this left many of the companies
in the middle such as HP Dell and
Toshiba in the dust Dell was also in a
similar position as Toshiba just a
couple of years ago but then complete
change your focus onto enterprise
products and servers and they were able
to survive the rapid change but Japan's
culture has prevented Toshiba from
making such a transition and while
they're still around today they're not
even comparable to the global giant they
once were only time will tell if Toshiba
it will turn things around by giving
consumers what they actually want but
unfortunately this is where Toshiba is
today but that's why I heart for you
guys in to Shilla make sure comment down
below what company you would like me to
cover next also if you guys like
together make up a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like some more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm all ready I'll see you guys on next
one
[Music]